so some historians have actually said
that the market revolution is more
revolutionary than the american
revolution actually this is a very
classic
ap u.s history question
which was more revolutionary the
american revolution or the market
revolution
but how could something actually be more
revolutionary than the american
revolution well it's because the market
revolution was a
confluence of inventions changes in the
way that the american people did
business and changes in the way that
people got goods to market that happened
in this period from about 1790 to 1850
so this is kind of a large period of
history and i don't think it's really
important for you to have a laundry list
of dates of exactly what when what thing
was invented but just kind of
take in the idea that in the first half
or so of the early 19th century there
were many new inventions in both factory
work and in transportation and
communication
and that how people did business changed
a lot
so i want to take some time to look into
all three
of these
revolutions the industrial revolution
the revolution in transportation and
communication and just the broader
market revolution so i know this is a
subset of itself but i'll get to that
and in this video i want to start out by
talking about the industrial revolution
okay so what was the industrial
revolution
this was broadly speaking a revolution
in the kinds
of machinery
that
people used to make finished goods
now if you think about the early
republic
in the united states you often think of
kind of an
agrarian
society and that was
how thomas jefferson the author of the
declarat declaration of independence
really imagined
the united states as a nation of small
farmers
but thomas jefferson didn't necessarily
see all of these revolutions in industry
coming he couldn't anticipate that and
so in the 1790s
early 1800s a bunch of new
inventions came to the united states
that completely revolutionized how
things were made so in this time period
the united states kind of slowly begins
its transformation from being a nation
of farmers
to a nation of people who
worked for wages
by the hour
and then used the money that they made
from that hourly labor
to buy the things that they need
so how did this happen
one event that historians often point to
is
the introduction of the
textile mill to the united states so
this fellow here i was named samuel
slater
and samuel slater was an englishman
who
worked in a textile mill and
remember that the united kingdom was the
world's capital of textile production in
this time
and they were so jealous of their
position as the world's leading textile
producer that they
even made it illegal to
export the plans for a textile mill
samuel slater decided that even if it
was illegal to export actual plans it
wasn't necessarily illegal to export his
brain
so
he
decided to memorize
how
these textile looms worked and this is
powered by a water wheel
and then
he actually got in disguise
put himself on a ship and came to rhode
island
to set up a textile mill
in fact
people were so angry that he did this
that in his hometown he's actually known
as slater the trader
so what was new about this well i think
the water wheel aspect
is really one of the key innovations
here so instead of being powered by
humans or perhaps being powered by
animals
now american machinery can be powered by
an outside source so water or steam and
that means that these mills and
factories later are going to kind of
congregate around sources of power like
rivers for example so if you've ever
wondered why so many american cities are
next to rivers it's usually because they
needed them to power mills
so starting in the 1790s and really into
the early 19th century there's this slow
transformation toward factory labor
and you can see in this image here that
a lot of the people actually laboring in
these factories were women because
you know young men kind of had a pretty
good path forward in life at this time
period they could be farmers like their
fathers maybe they could learn a trade
but for young women there wasn't
necessarily a form of income outside the
house
and so a man named charles lowell
uh decided to set up a whole series of
textile mills in what will be called
lowell massachusetts that's just outside
of boston
and then he
primarily employed young women to work
in these textile mills i think partly
because young women were
associated with working with fabric
women frequently did the spinning and
the sewing in the household but also
because young women you could probably
pay a little bit less
than young men for the same kind of
labor
so
so this is kind of a very slow
revolution toward
individual
work
right
because as if
a nation of farmers most people
would have worked in a family unit and
even some of the very earliest factories
in the united states would hire family
units it was known as the rhode island
system
by this time by lowell's mills
he started
hiring individual workers for individual
wages and the working conditions were
pretty brutal you know most uh
women at the lowell mills worked 12-hour
days uh
with no air conditioning remember this
is long before there's air conditioning
for pretty low wages i'd say probably
about three dollars a week
but despite the pretty harsh conditions
for many of them this was a really good
opportunity because it's the first time
in their lives they'd ever had
any chance to make money of their own to
be away from their families it's kind of
expected that
if you were a young woman in
massachusetts you wanted to go work in
the lowell mills
you could go there for a few years of
your life make a little bit of money
and then
go
back to your hometown meet someone get
married start a family of your own so it
kind of makes work for women outside the
home respectable
and textile production is going to
continue to ramp up in the united states
in the late 1840s
a man named elias howe
invents
a really excellent sewing machine he's
not the first man ever to invent a
sewing machine there were versions of
them stretching back to i think even the
1750s but howe's sewing machine brought
together a lot of different capacities
that made it kind of the best sewing
machine and it will be even further
refined by isaac singer
who we associate today with the singer
sewing machine and so
these
massive textile mills really become the
backbone of new england commerce
but they never would have gotten started
without another invention
which
was the cotton gin
and the cotton gin was invented by eli
whitney in 1793
and what's important about the cotton
gin so here's the gin
and basically it's kind of a box with
some spikes on it that allows you to
take
these
balls of cotton and separate them from
the seeds
and separating cotton from the seeds was
extremely labor-intensive process
if you've never held a ball of cotton
it's extremely sticky so you kind of
have to wade through the little bits of
cotton pull out these seeds
it takes forever and so an average day's
work would not produce all that much
cotton that was ready for market
well whitney completely revolutionizes
this with the cotton gin these little
spikes help
separate the cotton seeds from the
cotton ball
and revolutionizes how much cotton can
be produced by a single person in a
single day and whitney's cotton gin made
it possible for a single person to
process 50 pounds
of cotton in a single day which is just
an order of magnitude more than they
were able to do beforehand but this is
really interesting because it had kind
of a a massive human cost in the form of
really
bolstering the institution of slavery in
the american south
because when
farming cotton was so labor intensive it
really wasn't very profitable and so the
institution of slavery was actually
starting to die out a little bit
before the 1790s people were saying uh i
don't know if it's actually worth it to
keep slaves so if it weren't for the
cotton gin the united states might
actually have outlawed slavery
considerably earlier than it ended up
doing in the 1860s
so it's interesting to note that even
though these inventions really changed
the fabric of american society allowed
some people to earn money who'd never
been able to earn money before it also
meant that the institution of slavery
was really entrenched in the united
states and would only continue to expand
until the 1860s
so that's a little bit of a peek into
the human cost of the industrial
revolution and we'll get more into what
some of those costs were and what some
of the benefits were in the next video